[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la fusée falcon 9 d'école à l'heure
prévue images spectaculaires
une boule de feu illumine la nuit depuis
le centre spatial kennedy en floride
instant historique immanquable pour ces
américains venus immortaliser le premier
vol touristique de space x jared isaac
man à droite de l'image et le commandant
de bord c'est lui qui finance le voyage
fondateur d'une entreprise financière et
les milliardaires il a offert les autres
places à des inconnus dont cet homme
chris sands rose qui ancien pilote de
l'armée de l'air américaine à bord de la
capsule également deux femmes harley
arsenault assistante médicale qui a
survécu à un cancer et si yann proctor
une professeure de sciences qui avait
failli devenir astronaute en 2009 devant
rester en orbite pendant trois jours à
bord de la capsule cros dragonne de la
société dell admette space x à 575 km
au-dessus de la terre ils seront chaque
jour environ 15 fois le tour du globe ce
n'est pas rien a rappelé les américains
alors mortalité et il dit ceci beaucoup
ont réalisé qu'il ne fallait pas prendre
la vie au sérieux ils ont décidé de
faire les choses de manière impulsive et
c'est vrai que spontanément après la
série de confinement beaucoup
d'américains ont marqué leur peau avec
des dessins déjà de nature des dessins
d'animaux de compagnie de compagnie
qu'on a quand même beaucoup vu ces
derniers mois parfois les mots d'un vif
j'ai accepté que ma fille de 8 ans
des sites de vente à tout ça reste une
enfant donc
je suis hyper tendu je me dis j'espère
qu'avant par nos maîtres de la reine des
neiges un tatouage américains parlent
même d'une philosophie you look y aurait
un foyer ou en lan tête des américains
you you only once donc c'est
l'équivalent de caris & you live twice
monsieur james bond une fois sorte de
carpediem incantations général que enfin
lorsqu'on l'a prononcé qu'on s'apprête à
faire quelque chose qu'on va regretter
une connerie comme ce tatouage réalisé
par une américaine tatouage de rouleaux
de papier toilette pour représenter
l'année 2020
c'est trop beau
[Musique]
c'est un terme au real
c'est la première fois qu'on fait un
geste d'amour pareil réalisateur profite
également de cette interview pour
déclarer publiquement sa place à
laëtitia elle me plait pascal hérard
absolument unique jalil qui lui met
d'ailleurs des étoiles plein les yeux
puisqu'il a réalisé un de ses rêves les
plus chers jalil m'a aussi fait
découvrir le métro à 46 ans caché sous
un chapeau et un masque j'ai réalisé mon
rêve d'ado c'est comme si elle avait
quelque chose à cacher alors qu'il n'y a
rien à cacher quoi vin c'est dommage
annonçant confirme elle a rien à cacher
pas tous pas l'ouverture comme ça
mais un citron d'allant à la marque
sympa cette taxe est très bon point
jeanine et la santé j'ai pas besoin de
magritte son temps non non ça va je vais
porter bien
oui avec ma fille
la séquence atelier scellé il ya
toujours un fond de vérité dans
n'importe quel groupe pas du tout bois
ton d'emblée c'est comme ça de temps en
temps que je fais quand je présente
julia a des copains étudiants ma fille
moi c'est plus une vanne pour rigoler
mais ça l'a fait beaucoup rire aussi
d'ailleurs alors on n'a pas une grande
différence d'âge attention je suis pas
comme certains
il est trop jeune pour toi liliane lui
fait remarquer sa copine mais ça
n'arrête pas liliane qui en profitent
pour chanter du chayla avec emmanuel
macron
[Musique]
jacques est l'unique continent peut-on
croiser des cougars à l'état sauvage
[Musique]
parce que si on continue à tenir le bon
bout comme ça dans les départements bons
d'abord sur la forme est ce que vous
êtes étonné que ça se fasse sous que ça
se dissout que ça s'annonce comme ça
vous est donné
à tous fait le monde du silence avez
vous hâte rigolo
c'est drôle dit on tu bosses
tu recules
comment comment comment comment veux tu
que
c'est un cas rare mais extrême
d'addiction aux jeux vidéo un cas
clinique observée de près par des
chercheurs qui viennent de publier un
article scientifique révélant ainsi
l'histoire de cet adolescent suivi
depuis un an un espagnol de 15 ans a été
interné deux mois pour une trop grande
dépendance au jeu fortnight merci
pourquoi parce qu'on a convenu qu'on a
rouvert président confiant c'est très
dur
c'était pas
la console
département c'était dur j'ai racheté un
appartement qui appartenait goldman et
c'est son frère qui a signé pas biblique
ce film robert qui gère sa fortune et
sur l'appartement était sur doute assez
assez simple prêtre âgé des tours fait
dedans d'ailleurs acheté alors je
l'avais acheté une bouteille est jeudi
tous ses biens dont j'ai acheté à
l'époque deux millions quatre cent mille
euros
quand même magazine time magazine
américain sont un classement un seul
français figurent cette année et vous le
voyez vous le reconnaissez ici c'est
l'acteur omar sy qui figure parmi les
100 personnalités les plus influentes de
l'année omar sy qui est déjà connu en à
l'international depuis le succès du film
intouchables en 2011
pour les mohamed ce sera maximum les
kimberley deviennent gilberte et les
carlos second renommée charles avec le
site vite mon prénom des internautes
tourner en dérision une proposition
d'eric zemmour qui veut interdire les
prénoms étrangers s'il est élu président
c'est un boulet
tapez votre prénom s'il ne s'inscrit pas
dans la loi abrogée du 1er avril 1803 la
plateforme vous en a signé un autre pour
les maris pas de souci elles n'auront
pas à changer de prénom en 2022
m
les vrais mâles offrit le trompettiste
paru d'état à berne alors là voilà alors
vous êtes passées de ibrahim al aux
femmes à l'état ce parce que vous passez
vous même d'ibrahim maalouf à manitas
des l'habitat c'est terrible à 57 ans
regardez pas ça quelle honte je m'éclate
et comme une
m
sept ans j'étais chanteur